[Music]
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
it's the time of the week that we meet
up and look through all the map changes
that have happened in the last seven
days of fortnight Battle Royale this
week sees the end of week nine if you'd
like a full breakdown of every single
thing that has happened up to this point
then watch the video that I'm going to
link now it has everything and you'll be
up to date before you watch this one but
if you're ready let's do this oh I
almost forgot about my obligatory
begging moment if you like my fortnight
videos please think about using cold a
damaru it makes a massive difference to
me cheers big ears
so the stranger things crossover event
happened which has been hinted at all
season due to the ice cream store in the
mega mall it's the same one that's on
the Netflix show when the crossover
began held portals which I'm told leaked
to the upside down I admit I have no
idea what that means is now a good time
to also say that I've never seen
stranger things please give me a nudge
in the right direction should I watch it
after Game of Thrones ended I have
nothing to watch anymore anyway back to
the bottles these bad boys made
murdering people so much more fun debate
under weight taught me ah now ready for
it this way hey do it oh my god why is
everyone so suspicious that's probably
the reason why yep every single youtuber
in the world did that for 24 hours at
least
those were clips from music video should
definite
[Music]
over to the overarching storyline the
main plot of season nine this is the
upcoming battle between the polar peak
monster and the island robots after the
monster escaped the iceberg it quickly
jumped back into the sea and began
circling the island and he's done that
ever since to prepare for the imminent
attack the government have turned the
old volcano into a power plant and began
to build a hulking great robot by the
time I upload this video it will likely
have arms too but the main question is
what will happen when it's completed and
how will we know when the event starts
well that leads perfectly into another
edition this week there seems to be
electronic advertisements at various
places on the map they first show a
warning sign before they look like an
old world war 2 motivational image and
posters for example this image is taken
from the we can do it poster designed to
motivate female workers during the war
these will likely be used to show a
countdown to the event but they all also
give us clues about the future I'm going
to keep my best theory to myself for the
time being until I've made the season 10
video but look at what is being said
duck and hover get to high ground could
the entire island be at risk during the
event I hope so what areas of the map
are you happy to lose
[Music]
Oh something else which I noticed this
week which I need a little hand with if
you'd be so kind we all know the
original milk cartons in fortnight are
based on the blur music video coffee and
TV and by the way I can't show any of
that video or music because they take my
entire income if I do so thank you
Universal Media Group you complete FERS
I digress so the original cartons are
still here but almost all have been
modernized like this but get this there
is one here in the air base tent which
is different I've tried to figure this
out on my own but I can't I need your
help
who is this missing guy on the picture
and is this an easter egg please help me
out I need you and I need you to tell me
who this chap is I've named him roland
in the meantime
hashtag find Roland I'm losing sleep
over this people help me out
[Music]
/ - the magical moving duck which over
the last three weeks has been swimming
up the river he's shown us his salmon
esque resilience climbing up a damn
waterfall and now sits in loot Lake I
think I've figured it out maybe the
giant monster and the giant robots will
fight over the rubber duck okay is it
it's a terrible theory I know what could
happen next then now turn it over to you
guys
some people are reporting that there are
two ducks there now but when I checked
there's still only one how many do you
see watch right this is a big one we
started hot watch about four weeks ago
but cast your mind back a season or two
after Kevin the cube crushed the
original Shack we've waited seasons for
it to be rebuilt that process began in
season nine first the materials appeared
before the first layer was complete and
soon followed the second and then the
third which got us all very excited but
since then nothing I went back this week
to find yet more nothing nothing's
happening here I'm getting the feeling
will have to wait seasons to know what
will appear here although I gave it some
extra thought and I think this would be
a new modern house an architect's house
if you will here's my thinking remember
the og architects house above wailing
woods man and Miss wailing woods four
seasons it remained unfinished but
suddenly it became upgraded it became
brick something was going to happen
but then a freaking volcano landed and
ruined everything killing off risky
reels - and to add to that the other
modern house the one found in pleasant
park also bit the dust and sits in ruin
I believe the shack the hot watch Shack
will be a new building a new architect's
house growing season after season
changing materials upgrading what do you
think am I talking absolute works yes I
most likely am anyway I decided to go
down to the hood and finish the
architect's work for him hit the music
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and now I can reveal the new earth yeah
I made a huge package I'm a fully grown
man what the hell happened to my life
but one day boss Anna will be a reality
quick move on before I'm demonetised
again something that I missed over by
John wicks house have you noticed that
he's now got some solar panels these are
really cool by the way use these to
shoot people in Paradise pumps and it's
ridiculously easy so if you looked on
Rick's house just get on top of one of
these and shoot this of everyone easy
peasy
and finally the stone family the real
reason we're all here
stone cold rock the Dwayne Johnson and
Sharon Stone and their child kid rock
we've grown so much together we've seen
the mom and dad fight through lava to be
together we've seen the to start a
family and began to found the land above
lonely Lodge we've seen the boy go out
into the world and become independent
we've seen a stone dog urinating and
humping a tree but last week things got
real kid rocks are a flower and tried to
retrieve it his mama was scared stiff
she was bowled over by fear and then it
happened he slipped right now in the
game he is moments from falling to his
death his mother can't do anything his
father too far away to make it in time
only one rock creature can save the day
the dog he's noticed the predicament can
he save the boy or will he be crushed
under the boy creating a new human stone
dog hybrid thing seriously though how
the heck can the dog help the boy maybe
run around and grab him maybe build a
makeshift ladder have a guess in the
comments let's see who gets closest
so that's where we stand what will
happen next
I adore reading predictions so please
share your opinions and let me know what
will happen over the rest of this season
and what will be the theme of season 10
before I go a huge thank you to those
that have used code at Amaru I really
appreciate it you make it possible for
me to keep coming back to fortnight
every single week I thank you so much if
you want to be immortalized in a video
like these leggins
please use my code add Amaru to buy
something and send me a video Twitter
I'm Adam grenade over there it's that
simple right oh it's been a pleasure
I am I don't from PlayStation grenade
I'll see you next time
[Music]
Oh